hey guys Justin here and we're gonna be
playing divinity two today
now divinity one of course was it an
incredible Kickstarter success and
divinity to match that but I think
something that's really interesting is
that divinity 2 is going to be adding a
game master mode so I'm kind of a
dungeon to dragons way to play the game
and I'm here with spend the creative
director on the game to kind of explain
how this is going to work
ok so gay master mode was the final
stretch goal during Kickstarter campaign
and you're joined by our game master
lucid war and so he's going to run you
through a campaign which is a dungeon
dragons campaign it's the starter set
Edition campaign which is called lost
mines of endeavor and so you're going to
discover how it plays in divinity
original sin - so I hope you guys are
gonna have a lot of fun and this takes
fit addition rules and everything that
we would know about DD strip addition
right it's going to take the story and
the universe but it's going to use
divinity original sin 2 rules modified
by your game masters but you're about to
discover so you'll be fine
awesome well let's dive into this and so
the game master the DM for this is going
to be Edward and you're one of the
designers over on the game that's right
and I'm gonna be joined on the GameSpot
side by jean-luc on our video team and
Michael hi I'm one of our editors and
we've each taking a role we can go ahead
and get into our character creation
we've already kind of discussed this
we've talked about this I'm gonna be a
healer my name is Lady Jane I'm a I'm a
very noble health jean-luc what are you
gonna be doing
I'm a Wizards worth name taco I don't
have a backstory yet so I'm gonna kind
of figure that out as I go oh I should I
should go into my back store my back
story goes is uh means so I'm I'm from
the world of divinity too but I went to
visit France for a long time right right
I just switched over to America for a
bet I've learned a lot about French
cooking a really big fan of France and
general came back to divinity have a
little bit of a taste for human flesh
though guys I guess one of my abilities
is corpse eater and but I really like to
infuse that with a little bit of French
cooking and that's gonna be one of my
big things as both healer of the group
and a person who eats people
well thus will make it work
oh and I'm Lady Jane and Michael what's
your story i i'm quavo stun I'm a
fighter I was always a fighter you know
I was a grew up in the rough streets
with the with the I was raised by wood
elves they taught me how to fight damn
yeah so I'm gonna throw down today main
Wavell stun was good we're I'm fighting
I'll show you all the show thought of a
Baxter I didn't think of it so you're
gonna be taking us through kind of a pre
created campaign that's right we're not
just gonna be going willy-nilly into
this well you can if you want good yes
it's already prepared can you give us a
little bit of background about what what
kind of dangers will be I was going to
do that in instance but oh well it's
gonna be it's gonna be a journey journey
south we're gonna start in Neverwinter
first you're gonna be gearing up you're
gonna be in the shop and buying some
some gear for your wealth for the party
and then we will leave Neverwinter and
travel south of the high road to a place
called fender limit and maybe something
will happen on the way there who knows
and so the character creator is is
pretty robust and in that you're able to
choose both your abilities uh tags kind
of the things that we know from D&D
you're able to describe your character
and create these these stories in this
stuff that doesn't necessarily play
directly into the game but lets you
create your own world your own character
and design right well here yes
absolutely and in the game master
Mallick and that's the thing in the game
where you're really free so we can
decide to take that into account or not
maybe I can take a look at your tags and
we can decide to like you know use this
in your backstory maybe for instance I
see do you have chosen a noble tag and
maybe when you're going to try to
remember the custom of certain people
certain noble people or nobility I can
take that into account and give you a
modifier to your role
maybe all right so should we we also
have a musical instrument here the reach
able to pick that's right I grabbed the
cello yeah how is that going to affect
the game so essentially this is a dusty
feature that happens when when you
create your chi tier you can select an
instrument and this instrument is going
to play when it's your turn in combat
when you've done something awesome when
you
I landed a critical hit or whatever for
the gamemaster mode it's more a matter
of roleplay you can pretend that you're
bent Bart's maybe and that everybody's
got different instruments it can be
anything that we want but the game
master mode doesn't at the moment I'm
not you doesn't use this feature all
right so I think we can just go ahead
and jump right in right yeah I think so
all right all right so drunk green right
now we're all playing on a line we're
all playing locally but this is also
something where you could play with
people anywhere absolutely yes
absolutely is okay all right
oh that's how you spell taco I didn't
see any more taco okay so taco and
[Music]
that's really interesting so we have a
little bit yeah just yes head yes please
and have a technical difficulty with the
network's I'll accept that
all right okay guys this is I'm just
gonna wait for Justin to be back with us
there we go okay this is the pause
screen this is a new feature it allows
the game master to pause the game so I
can keep telling the story so like
players don't start like clicking
everywhere and like and like breaking
stuff yeah which you will be able to do
anyways if you hit if you hit I you can
see your stats so this is where the game
starts today we're going to be playing
D&D so I would like to run you through
the stats correspondences that we have
Indian do you know okay in D&D
when you want to do something you're all
a d20 you can click that yeah okay you
can you know Lizzy 20 so the game master
for instance if you want to like lift a
rock the game master sets a difficulty
check in in his head that says this rock
looks really heavy it's going to be a 15
so you have to roll 15 on the on the
dice to make that happen however you
have stats so if you look at the first
yeah the first tab and you have
attributes strength finesse intelligence
Constitution memory widths and these are
we're going to be using them
if you have for instance 12 finesse
that's gonna give you a plus 1 on the
finesse rule if you have 14 that's gonna
be a plus 2 so this is how this works
and I'm going to ask you every time you
go to modifier in this or that stats of
course I can check it for you but this
is how the system is going to work okay
guys are you ready yeah yeah let's go
see what happens all right this is a map
of the northern Sword Coast a place
famous in Dungeons and Dragons you are
now in Neverwinter as you can see the
little group there is you guys so you're
you just left in Neverwinter a dwarf
named Gunnar and walk seeker as hired
you to bring a wagon load of provisions
to a settlement called pendulum so that
is going to be your quest you are
sporting a wagon food provisions there's
like cows you know pulling it and this
is what you're gonna be doing southeast
of Neverwinter so you can see fendall in
which is a little yellow in there gunned
Rijn then set gunner in so the guy who
hired you then set the head of you on
horse along with a warrior escort named
silver Hall winter claiming you needed
to arrive early to take care of business
so you left before you got before like
like yesterday so he's not with you
anymore
in fact I'll in the wagon should be
brought to a shop called Barton's
provision for reward so you have been
traveling for about 10 days on the high
roads it's the end of the year autumn
you know leaves falling shadows becoming
shorter it's nice weather and you're now
arriving at a fork that that leaves the
high road to go into the forest on the
tribe or trail it's called this way
because goes all the way east to a
village called tribe or but you're not
going to go there unless this
what you guys wanna do your plan is to
go to fender then we have to drop off
this wagon that's right I'm serious
what's in the leg I'm very happy you
asked I need to know what I'm
transporting before we transfer it
before answering that I just want to
like give you a couple tips so you're on
the tribe or trail now this is sunny
you know ultimate afternoon it's great
end of the day very nice here this is a
pen and paper experience so you can do
whatever you want if you can think of
something you can probably do it so like
usually examples of actions you know
include inspecting things taking a look
at something trying to get details
trying to find secrets trying to find
traps for first couple levels or so I'll
help you I'll give you like hints you
know and let's just do it so these two
cows are pulling the wagon they're
carrying your stuff
ideally they don't die they don't end up
being barbecued or chopped off or like
you know you know peppered with arrows
and this is the wagon inside you find
two big pieces of ham some beer you find
some some sturdy rope two pieces you
find four sleeping bags in which you
have been sleeping actually you've been
using them and some like mining supplies
such as like pickaxes shovels and all
that what's the plan
so is there anything suspicious around
here anything I do see something
suspicious okay let's take a look real
quick
Lady Jaye please roll for wits wits is
what we're going to be using using a
sari for the wisdom checks of Dungeons &
Dragons is there's correspondence you do
not notice anything suspicious with a
five cat so everything seems good guys I
think we should just you know go on I
don't notice anything suspicious I
believe you you're the wise one around
here I suppose mm-hmm there's a yellow
dot this way
that's what I mean all right are you
running towards did you see what you saw
what you saw right now I see what I see
I said I'm kind of witless apparently
all right just running right into this
now wolf stands in the middle of the
trail rolling snarling it's fierce fangs
flashing in the afternoon Sun like
bloody blades it's busy feasting on a
dead horse is flesh what are you going
to do and so this time it gives us some
some options where are these things that
the Dungeon Master can create I can
create yes so for instance if you think
that these three options are stupid you
don't want to do any of these you can
tell you know I want to I want to sing
the new song of my people or I want to
dance or whatever and I will add this on
the fly for you guys to vote on so you
can tell me whatever you want
I'm all for picking up a stick throwing
the let's fetch yeah dogs dogs wall so
the wolf is eating is like really like
you know is busy eating so if you pick
up a stick and throw in wood you'll have
to be like convincing I think like
Jurassic Park in t-rex if you remember
this does anyone have the ability to
speak to animals in our party maybe we
could talk to the wolf man I was raised
by wolves where you go you didn't
mention that I thought you were raised
by fellow and an wolves lot of streets
yeah it was tough man
I don't live with no humans I throw it
down anyone who mess with me man but so
can we try to reason with the wolf maybe
he's a he could be friendly you know
yeah I think I could try but if not I'm
ready to throw down and I think I'm
taking a look at everybody's talents and
I don't see anybody having pet ball yeah
I got nothing yeah I mean there's just
like as as a fan of wolves and dogs like
I just want to try to make friends with
it as what a pet it you know what I'm
looking at it it's looking vicious real
vicious that doesn't be looking vicious
doesn't mean that it is true it's hungry
it's eaten yeah Chuck I'm wanna see you
know if he's gonna be friendly to us if
we like hey hey what's up puppy maybe
offer him a little bit of food my bag
will you offer in my arm no you guys
okay wait I say we've really but if
things go bad y'all better have your
hands on your weapons I'm saying all
right I'm just saying all right guys
we're gonna befriend the wolf yes so
that some feel I feel that okay guys all
right
the wolf is eating he noticed you two is
looking at you you know keeps eating but
like keeps an eye on you will say
furthest back you know I'm the magic
person I got range
right I'll stand sighs oh that's that's
that's that's close enough
the wolf starts barking OH oh no I'm
really not happy about what you're doing
are you okay lady uh Drive anything I
can give the wolf yes see if I usually
Mackey its mild-tempered yeah he's not
he's not attacking outright it did not
attack outright huh he respects me
does it though so what's the client
Wednesday had playing so maybe you're
the one who should be I don't know I'm
gonna take the lead on this mom says I
say we he's howling what if we can make
him let's try and make him a companion
trying to like tainment oh yeah like i
know quick oh yeah we got to get to know
but like he wants to roll with us and
get our backs we could get his back too
mm-hmm life we want to be friends with
him so you said that you were raised by
elves and wolves yes so I would like you
to roll intelligence to see exactly how
much of
that you can remember it's been a while
I am in I am a grizzled veteran yeah
let's try it though well look at ending
with your score well uh I'll see what we
can alright let's see what I got mm-hmm
all right it's a seven it's not
brilliant uh what can I say let me think
so you it seems to you that the wolf is
like like territorial and is like eating
right now so you should probably like
either offer him like an even bigger
piece of food or wait until it's done
but you should not get too close another
if you if you get close like you did one
more time you will attack okay oh no at
this point I say gotta leave him be with
y'all what do y'all think yeah we can
let him enjoy his what's he eating there
was dead horse yeah I miss dad like
there's nothing we can do it sound like
I want revenge for that but it's someone
who grew up with wolves you would know
whether he's being a design I understand
hizmet a leader and I was like yo let me
have this meal real quick and we don't
want to give him one of our auction cuz
there and I think he would eat the oxen
we walk too close to them
because we need to bring the ollie look
he's got a lot on his plate right there
he's not even halfway done with that so
he's pretty busy so I don't think he's
gonna I think that's a horrible idea
that sounds like that this is that like
a good idea I think they should get the
amount of that intelligence not close to
the wolf okay
and give you an option you have to be
safe Thanks yeah leave them alone we'll
go around
remember our main objective we got
transport this stuff man yeah so we
can't be messing around with things you
don't need too much would have been nice
to be his friend but I'm not tripping
all right let's go back and try to find
a high road guys there's a signpost
there and I just want to say in exterior
areas like that there's gonna be like
signpost to like light episode yeah I
you need to ask me if you're like
reading it so I can tell you you know
what what there is all right this one is
pretty obvious west to the high road
where your guys are coming from east to
Finland oh so we're going the wrong way
anyway you should go east a federal it
yeah it's like this way pass the wolf
essentially also we have to go we have
to pass by them and
oh well this this is a little bit
complicated how fellas there's three of
you guys maybe ha I didn't want to do
this yeah but what if what if I turn him
to stone temporarily yeah and then we
just get past him don't work in turn to
stone so we volume after her exact let's
do that that is sounds like a sound plan
okay lady Lady Jane what you think yeah
yeah we can stone him we can get him
still that sound like someone would do
all right
all right so that is going to be
petrifying touch trip yeah that I'll
just use it
okay you can you can try it out okay
here's what's gonna happen you guys
you're gonna be trying this is a touch
this is a short-range though so you
gonna like if you want to like sneak up
to all do you want like be discreet if
that if it doesn't work for any reason
the wolf will attack because wave will
told you so
and cueva noses [ __ ] I try I try sneak
so I have some extra like sneak driven
heritage do you though okay alright how
do I see so you have finesse I'll handle
it for you and you don't have any
particular penis roll so go ahead be
discreet all right
13 yeah I am pretty discreet so the wolf
has how much passive detection 12 so
that's alright please okay just jet try
it try it try this Bell yeah try it wolf
is still still eating you screen you can
hit see to sleep like in DOS okay let's
go petrifying touch you're gonna get it
you have to touch it yes you have to
touch it my something casual oh yeah
because the wolf is looking at you but
don't worry but I like the shine golf
yeah
taken that's really cute going okay okay
it's happy hour this is I'm gonna jump
and do jumping jacks oh he distracts the
wool okay and Steven failed and it not
work
yeah I think it worked huh I think it
works so essentially the wolf is going
to be petrified for some time sorry guys
I paused the game because I need to set
something up it's all good and there you
go so well played that was very cool
that was very cool so the wolf is
petrified for now do you guys you know
that the spell is gonna last for some
time do you want to take a look at the
dead horse that's there
do you want to take a look at the world
yeah which I examine look what like is
there did the wolf kill a horse
probably alright so I know this we're
stuck I'm gonna tell you what you see
like like this at first sight and then
we'll roll wits to see if you like can
get in details this is a this is a
travel horse it's about like saddlebags
so it's well it's pretty dead the first
thing that you notice of course apart
from the wolf like ripping its entrails
and like feeding on it there's blood
everywhere
it's like three
arrows sticking out of its neck
everybody will fool everybody looking at
the horse please vote for wits and you
guys will look at the horse yeah we're
all fries go ahead yeah three to sixteen
and sorry I didn't didn't catch your
last one hmm it's at 11 okay so indeed
surprise quavo sixteen that's this
pretty good actually I've been doing
this my whole life
all right so Yugi you notice that the
hooves of the horse are quite dusty this
horse has been traveling from for quite
a distance what else what else was these
these arrows they don't look like this
is not good craftsmanship they are like
like like and a real scratch da so it's
possible the wolf created those arrows
and shot it and it's not fire you know
it doesn't matter that my possible also
there is something in the grass near
divorce okay it's like a little like
empty like leather Kay's like a tune
that you know and you've seen that like
used for like maybe traveling licks
carrying Scrolls or the map yeah so it's
empty though but yeah so I would like I
would like
probable tool for intelligence real
quick let's go
little smart I think I know what's going
on 13 yeah 13 is not so bad I'm actually
yeah and you've seen that horse before
you've seen him you fall you can't you
can't put your finger on there but
you've seen that horse before you could
swear that you have seen them like you
know this horse where could you have
seen it huh what it man it looks like
you know maybe like 20 years ago I was
doing the same thing transporting cargo
with two horses this looks like that one
of them horses that was carrying that
cargo you feel that you've seen it
pretty recently though I wasn't like
about like a week ago like 10 days maybe
I'm not that smart but you got to do the
important part was that you feel that
you've seen it before where could you
have seen like reasonably not in 20
years ago huh
maybe I visited the stables I was trying
to register a horse okay
anybody want to help is anybody will
enroll for intelligence to help quavo
like Sora's memories yeah I'm kind of
stumbling on this one
yeah I'll roll for intelligence okay
lady Jaime want to help yes okay treat
oh I yeah dozen so I got a bad idea
and I'm still on the I think Lee the
wolf might have made the errors don't
you feeling you guys want to take a look
at the areas of what yes yeah yeah
everybody does that intelligence please
if you have any bonus any modifiers and
there was the time to tell me got a one
if you have more than that's right if
you have more than them yeah you did
if you have more than 12 for instance
that's that's not a 1 that's a 2 for
instance 14 alright that's that's that's
okay taco
arrows this is poor craftsmanship
they're like barely like twigs that are
like cut to be a little point all right
and they're like black as in like as if
they had been blackened by fire
goblins do that all right
Goldman's do that okay guys I think some
goblins I'm gonna have killed this horse
that apparently you know about this
horse you seen this horse before can't
quite put my finger on it may have been
20 years ago maven 10 days ago its Clark
at somewhere between quibble are you
taking the little empty leather cases
yeah I'm taking that so it's it's in
your inventory it's looks it's pouch
it's named pouch and Cena's not right
but this is what it is it's an empty
leather case it's in your bag now what's
the plan guys
you guys can take a look around you guys
yours a free to like like you know
Saoirse area or when you want to move on
you let me know removal does it go works
are we a little worried about the
petrifying spell run it out or you
muscle their dough alright gotta be fun
now I trust see that dress I say we go
on the this guy's petrified they're
probably goblins around but they're
really crappy yeah arrows yeah they have
like yeah their weapons are wax ain't
gonna do nothing else we're level one
Warriors we're good time still worries
still throw it down I think that you
know I think we safe for now do we need
to get the wagon and bring it
there's no the wagon move for me oh cool
I say we just go I say alright there's
there's more to see alright guys and we
got to see it let's go hi
it's coming on edge a little bit mm-hmm
all right there's so you move on and
there's like ruins here as you can see I
stand up today it's very nice but
there's like another massive dead horse
in the middle of the trail and it looks
pretty much like the previous one like
like um travel horror cell bags
everything so I have a taste for flesh
can I eat the corpse and get some
memories so goes what happened why not
it's good you get its memories yeah
that's why that's why I you think he's
an elf
okay I will not so this is like a racial
tray so I will not like ask for a roll
maybe I could though I'm thinking trying
to think how to make this work okay I'm
gonna ask for a roll but they will just
it will still work if you if you fail
but it will just like you know like let
me know the amount of information that
you're getting from taking a bite from
the dead horse but don't worry if you
fail yeah four is not great but Dori
alright alright as you sink sink I'm
sorry as you sink your teeth into the
flesh of the horse you like you feel you
see in the back of your mind like
memories like pouring into your interior
into your brain
the horse was was there he was walking
there was somebody on top of him like it
felt the weight of something on its back
and the horse looked to the left and he
saw the rocks that you're seeing there
and to the right and I'm sorry to the
right and to the left into the lefty
there was another horse which looks
awfully similar to the horse who just
left and there was somebody there like a
dwarf a dwarf riding that horse but you
don't know who wrote that particular
horse cuz it couldn't see you know in
Bangla said and then at some point a
powerful pain you know really had the
horse like like its flank something
really hurt him and the horse lost
balance it started falling and it felt
you know the grass and the dirt
walks on its cheek and everything where
the book this is what happens all right
so I think I've established the horse
diet is hell is real dead he's real dead
though yeah I'm gonna guess it's goblins
pink goblins like shot him with arrows
and threw him off balance and that's how
just bled to death just look at that
trail man I saw that's a lot of blood
you feel the pain of the horse like as
you open your eyes you feel something
your flank as if you have been you of
course it doesn't really it's not really
pain but it's like the same sensation we
know this one has arrows in it as well
if you take a look I can tell you yeah
let's look at so that's the Allan single
so it's obviously peppered in arrows
feel like four arrows in its flank one
of them is pierced through the heart or
two something important is that reciting
I'm sick I'm so good are they like
terribly made arrows as well absolutely
yes they're the same oh they're the same
same arrows that's how he'll is on the
loose can we can we look around just
make sure there's no immediate danger of
us also getting peppered with arrows
well I'm as an outlaw I've decided I'm
an outlaw yes partly Baxter I feel like
that this area is very set for a
potential ambush if I was trying to
ambush people and steal their stuff this
is a good place to do it yeah look at
this there's three four entry points man
we're almost sitting ducks if we move
any further I would like everybody to Oh
for wit space which is like your general
perception it's going to get thirteen
nine sorry I didn't catch the last one I
rolled if it did you're old okay okay
guys I'm thinking okay so essentially 13
is okay but not so great
so you taco you hear something coming
from the ruins and so you can't
investigate but you don't know what that
is it's like like a breathing wing or
something like that but something that
is barely human
barely human right that's for sure all
right you go take a look but all I think
the person with the biggest the hardest
armor should probably just go in and let
me look over there there's obviously
something there let's have a la I'm a
healer
she's a wizard over here mm-hmm I'm
ready to throw down
Lichter you what you want to get in
there so good job yeah we were gonna
yeah we there's this whole passage over
here she will try kind of sneaking in
from the side like you going in the
front okay
well kind of come in from the side me I
talked about this stony gateway right
here yeah okay there's a there's a
there's an oh hold on hold on but
there's an active fireplace fire
campfire in there you can see it yeah
it's burning so I was also a signpost
what is the signpost say it's too you
too far to see you would need to stand
right there and my eyesight's bet I'm
gonna go look at the signpost
is that even a good idea yeah yeah don't
you don't trip I got what I got your
package okay go for it go for it we got
you yeah and as you approach the
signposts you see movements in the
bushes around you oh there's something
clearly taco you were right and then you
have been ambushed by goblins I knew it
but I don't know why don't take a look
at the sign points good timing their
bows in your direction grinning smiles
of yellow decaying fangs there Alton
Alton breeze carries their stench your
nostrils foul odors of sweat filth and
the distinctive smell of bad breath
fills the air gave a swaggin one of them
hisses get and the blood gets spilled
what would we do hey you just see we
have character voices my gangster voice
is like my real voice oh yeah oh it's
almost because I am I'm a lady I refuse
I think we should try to parlay though
because I'm French I was living in
France and but I kind of picked up a
southern affectation of like a southern
belle okay before I came back to the
world today I think we should try to
parlay what I've like a deeper something
like a divorce to do Jordan Lee sound
like a deeper like
yeah that's why can you work that and
say I'm Batman
I bought it had me feel cool uh it's
your choice essentially well I mean
dwarf speaks I think goblins don't
really you know you can't really
parlayed with them but you're welcome to
try
um yeah I think we should parlay you
never know a little bit of southern
hospitality goes a long way this is what
I picked up in France when I was living
in indeed this America this earth world
but I visit I know nothing about French
or croissant sir
and if things go badly I'll just eat
them says jean-luc huh you know I say we
throw it down homie like all right look
goblins
ain't nothing like you know uh I'm gonna
give them our wagons our objective is to
transport these wagons these fools want
something well they ain't gonna get it
and if they ain't gonna get it
we throw it down like almonds like trust
me Gambas is the worst growing up yo I I
do not like this it is very rude of them
to just ask out right exactly we should
just kill them now yeah yeah do that
let's just kill so you guys like
refusing draw your weapon yeah yes when
you guys do Plus go all right let's go
very well then I need just a second to
set that up cuz every time it's
different every time I
no like players doing other things so I
need to set it out real quick
everybody won't take long I don't want
my scream stop I that was gonna buy a
video a cheating I don't know what she
was doing that's that's my general
strategy and all games is to cheat is to
find a way you look at the game master
screen and like to leech eco it's like
if nobody sees like when you're playing
a board game if nobody sees you roll
your dice sometimes you can just kind of
tweet yeah okay guys the governments
have seen you so you've seen three of
them three of these guys there's as you
can see two in the ruins they're the
wolf looks awfully similar to the one
that you've seen before and there's this
guy in the tower there so just to be
fair in divinity divinity origin
original sin to when you have an enemy
that is standing on top of you they get
damage bonuses same for you by the way
if you manage to like reach that
position so we have vantage points so
it's usually not really cool for the
Goblin to be there because he might deal
quite a bit of damage if he manages to
hit any of you which is not the case
right now so it's going to move and try
to like relocate we can't see any of you
which is good for you guys ah you can
see quavo so go yeah oh oh I hurt the
grunts just like like I'm screaming ah
give us wagon and we'll
you know faction points to attack which
is actually yes it does oh man a sucker
punching yeah yeah the wolf is here and
and run stars Lady Jane invites your
turn guys yeah bite boy Oh smack this
fool in his face but you have your
spell's here yeah and that's right
so you can take a look at what you want
to do okay no one get near those oil
barrels that's a bad idea
rollit if we lure them over to the oil
barrels I have fire will I do that we
can absolutely do that so what you can
do for instance this is we're using the
divinity combat system which you can
pretty much what you want you can like
try to like grab one of them I'll ask
you to roll for strength and we'll
compare your strength and if you want to
like throw him into the oil whatever you
want to do you can talk to them you can
do whatever you what if you pick up that
wolf and just like just sue
pro-wrestling just like throw it
suplexes through place they're right
here to move let's say that I don't
think that I could suplex a wolf that's
fair checks bear check this I got battle
stomp I love you stomping all these
tools in my team's right so and I think
that it within my range I can battle
stomp and it knocks them to the ground
I'm knock these fools down okay so I
think I can get both this goblin and
that wolf in one in one move alright so
I'm gonna try and do that um see if it
lines up trust me hopefully you don't
else down Jane I can go ahead go ahead
cook it by the way but by all means I'm
sorry go ahead
yup alright check this Oh Tom you gotta
govern them nice wolf still up so
careful
oh so much oh I saw a more AP Oh Oh Tina
all right so I have a variety of spells
nobody is doing really badly on hit
points though right I think we're at red
is our cue points well good yeah yeah I
think we're good I'm good I'm not jr.
yeah so I'm gonna I'll use this decaying
touch my necromancer power because to
see how effect that is against our our
wolf friend this is right next to me no
okay so probably like the natural like
physical shield the wolf absorb the
effects but you got rid of the shield
doing so so it's fine it'll do ah I knew
you had done you have not done it yet
very cool
okay yeah the wolf looks sick and sad it
works so what this does essentially is
that if anybody tries to heal him it
damages him it reverses the effect at
you and then I'm going to try this flush
sacrifice
all right so you're gonna use yeah I'm
just attacking home yeah Eric
all right chuckle all right a lot of my
stuff's fire-based
which might not work well with you guys
so close by mm-hmm oh dang a fire you
have anything ranged enough to take care
of that guy who's gonna be shooting us
yeah right I'll try to think about this
he he painted it's really far away
quibble son I know he sniping me man so
he's got it right there is 100 rounds -
yeah not even close
taco did you want to move up closer and
try and get in range or is it like way
out of range its way out of range
um yeah no I don't want to I feel like
if I try and run up to I'm just gonna
get peppered and it's not a good idea
very least I can I can shoot some bass
magic at this your fear mm ask you ask
you actually
stink distinctive smell of burnt hair
fills the air no yeah it's like he's
smell so great smelling my mixtape yo
spire spire oh that's all a fire topic
and there you go that was a little
bigger than I imagined uh I wasn't quite
expecting right so essentially what
happens now is uh was a fight relax even
blown away by the explosion a little bit
so I'm gonna make that happen real quick
[ __ ] have you just drop it apo my put
you there
she went platinum or a little bit I'm
sorry you can be knocked down for Walter
cuz ya in the wolf as well oh I do
declare an explosion very oh sorry lady
he's like fire everywhere so the Ranger
well is very surprised that what just
happened but he can still target quavo
though so he's gonna shoot very sorry
about that hey we got any water water
spells no wow that took a lot okay uh so
the wolf is knocked down so the grunt is
on fire
so the grunt I know wait that's all
right so um right so whose turn is it
fine it's your turn flavor
go ahead on that man I got a backup
I gotta take some cover then oh no I
didn't know okay okay okay okay I'm
gonna move would get just around just on
the tip of this whoa a type of
opportunity yeah you right
forgot about that oh I'm off the drain
oh my god yeah you need a potion or
something uh great tirta let's go nice I
got all I got one more AP man let's see
you're very close to fire though it's
not the first time it's not the first
time I'm gonna stand in fear with the
fire let's see what you done that song
doesn't sound very of this work well you
know I grow I got my cello so I'm laying
down bass lines write my own [ __ ]
okay let's let's encourage everyone up
your attributes wait okay just took
anger okay
I'm encouraging that's right we can do
it is yeah I need a family where actual
um just uh be careful that's my that's
my pipeline like that works watch it
watch your bag don't don't walk away
from someone it's less than inspiring
when they when they're in front of you
it is less than aspiring but it's
practical it's like a warning yeah so I
got back stem and I don't want that to
happen again
Oh how much good so this guy yeah
alright so well the Ranger can't really
shoot anybody and more which is really
frustrating for him cuz that's what he
does it shoots people so just keep
stirring this guy here the grunt is on
fire so he freaks out hahahaha trying to
run away Oh take so long yeah I did not
squirrel see me it happens to me as well
so he I freaking out it's trying to run
away you notice that is running away in
this particular direction
hello Lou your turn quite know who I was
that's a little fishy right there he's
probably retreating to his home he's
really he's gonna run away so be it we
got bigger fish we got bigger goblins to
fry I'm really a really where's that
where's this shooter like oh I am come
down here and face me 1v1 y'all like
good tired of this little arrow planking
oh mama bro that's like hmm
alright y'all up y'all are good where's
uh where's my lady she's on the ground
because she was wrong
can I pick her up yes yes why I got you
oh oh how can you do that thinking I'm
gonna ask you to roll for strength I
guess gonna be really easy though
because you're a big guy and she's
really like frail Holly oath ring and if
you have yeah f12 so that's I'm sorry I
I asked the wrong I was thinking of the
elf and I asked the elf doll for
strength
go ahead sorry that's an 8 that's 9
that's that's enough that size would be
no so what happens is that you are not
knocked down anymore
well thank you good sir forgot your bet
very cool very cool m'lady I don't know
the big deal it's just a little bit of
fire just like it's fine all right let
me see I'm gonna try and wait where's
the wolf at the what was there is
knocked down and burning okay cuz you
like knocked down by your local
explosion let me see okay I got this
right here so I'm gonna move in a little
bit closer to wolf but still out of
range or hopefully still in cover from
that guy up there in so I move up Oh
burning I may have made more so it's
fine okay for shelf shelf I'm gonna
smack this fool real quick ah see what I
got I'm just do a basic attack let's get
it oh all right cool very cool tech oh
it's your turn okay to the fire you know
is gone but the smoke will still
prevents you from seeing what's
happening on the other side so you will
not be able to like target so keep that
in mind okay but neither could could
this guy up here he couldn't see me
either the Ranger yeah that's right he
wasn't able to target futures now oh we
won't be able to see me the smoke
absolutely yes if you were in the smoke
it could not even not even Tory's you
probably I'm gonna I'm gonna head in the
smoke and try and see if I can get
closer to him oh very smart
that is very clever entering but you
can't see out of the smoke yeah yeah I
can sneak attack hmm see it as close as
I can here mm-hmm
all right you smarter no check out and
say that it's pretty smart oh no it's my
turn all right so I'm going to start off
with some healing I have some
restoration resource vitality
[Applause]
I'm gonna hook me up Quibbler stomach oh
yeah see I got your bag you got mine
that's how we do do this thing
it's my basic attack of range attack
yeah yeah right you can just like I'm
gonna get the foot I think what are you
carrying could oh nice nice to see ya
you have some sort of Club all right the
Goblin
well yeah you're in still in smoke you
can't see you that is that is very very
well played actually and the government
can't see anybody so what the Goblin is
going to do is going to climb down the
ladder and and that will be his turn yes
the croc mock grunt our runs away which
is the boundaries of the level and
disappears quavo it's your turn all
right I say we got to take care of this
this wolf hit while we while we can so
I'm just gonna lay down two basic
attacks keep it simple
very cool the wolf does this burns to
death and the Goblin has no idea where
you are it doesn't see anyone anymore
wait let me let me handle that
differently all right the smoke clears
and the Goblin sees you all right and it
is really surprised because it had no
idea and looks around and doesn't see
his friends what do you guys do real
quick like you can you have taco you
have an opportunity to either like
intimidate him into like our
surrendering or you can just attack and
resume to fight I was gonna just burn it
yeah you wouldn't do that let's find out
it's weekend we can find out what else
is going on all right yeah cuz it all
you know you know I'll try I'll try it
to me okay cuz that that grunt ran away
we want to know what he's running to
okay
maybe problem alright Tech oh that's
gonna be wits intimidate this guy
goblins are usually stupid that is 10
yeah
not really intimidated sorry oh you can
try to hurt him some more
see what happens he's gonna shoot you
because that's what he did
oh man yeah and then he's going to try
to move to see his friends because he's
starting to realize maybe that
everybody's gone and he's really really
concerned that his friends are dead
huevo I'm gonna try and on one corner
this fool like make sure he got no
escape so I'm just gonna use I'm just
gonna I'm a backup taco right here so
I'm just gonna move up you know if he
shoots me so beat it all right all right
tackle
well Topco is a dangerous person to
stand next to yeah you owe us a nice
play
yeah whatever I'm attacking at least a
fire soldiers name well I'm gonna do
what I always would I know how to do
which is set people on fire
yeah I'm not really a smartest
are you cardamon oil which is a good
precursor oh no it's still next to it
yeah I'm fresh out the kitchen okay oh
hey ignition though all right
that's the remix and I go around the
other side of you very cool hole
flangers yeah very nice to see in my
inventory I think I'm not weird
using my wand and the sound tech was
back any James bank
oh you taco has a wand mm-hm should take
that from you at some point why am I not
using it I have two ones the makeshift
one yeah I'm gonna see if I can get
closer and use a decaying touch all
right think I have to touch to do that
yeah just go right up to him he'll be
fine ooh okay so the Goblin hands now is
now completely surrendered ice close to
the iron fire and start screaming I no
more no more no more right and he's
going to drop his weapon cuz that's what
goblins do and he surrenders essentially
he could jump into that on if he wants
to yeses is his weapon
what's the plan guys grabbing is what
that's how we yeah we'll talk to a boy
yeah all right I've got justice is it a
sticky situation so he has no choice you
have captured the last of the governance
it gives you a panic look as it tries to
struggle free its putrid rule flying
left and right it's black Oh back eyes
going back and forth between your party
and what's left of his let go he hisses
and go now what are you gonna do well
shouldn't let him go definitely don't
know no yeah don't do that
nothing questioning him question yeah
find out what's who else is around it I
want to know what is the size and I like
100 or that other guy would yeah that's
so we're questioning government okay
guys all right I'll consider that
government here is badly wounded
absolutely terrified slaughter his
friends
slaughters dogs like everybody what do
you ask how many of you are there so to
do that sir are we gonna get one
question
no okay it's good how are we going to
handle this is gonna depend on like your
success on the rubble especially apply
the higher score however we're going to
be using a DND rule that's called
advantage because like you is really
intimidated as wounded there's three of
you you've just won essentially so I'm
gonna let you roll with advantage
meaning you guys gonna get to roll twice
and we'll select the highest
okay if that's cool with you guys yeah
how I roll
all right Chris who's doing the talking
lady who is the smartest among us
okay let's take a look that's gonna be
wits it's going to be Whittle
intelligence it's your choice
essentially you can try to like you
witty or reason with them so it's your
choice really I see that quavo has 12
wits that's a plus one on the wall I see
that tacho is 12 intelligence that's
plus one as well and so does lady
Jeannie
good choice I think good I think taco
you should take point on this one
Kevin said cuz I said I'm on fire yeah
yeah you're obviously an intelligent
negotiator all right we trying to figure
out we're coming from nominee who else
how many of them are granted yeah so
what are we dealing with exactly how
many of there how many are there of you
if you're good in English let's do it in
goblin yeah it speaks common tongue but
it's this coupling don't use words are
too complicated
can you please volume intelligence right
alright let's do it again and we'll take
the highest and that's it so that's here
we eight so it's not so great yeah eight
plus one so that's nine it's not so
great but you manage
to understand from what the Goblin is
saying there's quite a number of them
the government you know that it can't
count so it's not going to tell you how
many of them but there's a lot not just
not here they're not here there's a loan
you want to try something else what else
should realize I said why are y'all here
like like what y'all doing oh y'all
scavenging or y'all Pope where y'all
post it up that's what I want to ask you
know that you can like use your strength
just like shaking and do something like
that you want to try that yeah I'm not
gonna grant the advantages also that is
going to be mmm that is going to be
strength as well you don't have a
particular bonus you want to use
strength or wits or are you want to get
strength
I'll handle this and adults a business
real quick okay so that's that's good
actually please try that again just
because you have advantage okay that's
15 that's really good actually you
understand that they were waiting for a
certain dwarf and that dwarf was
carrying a map he's not sure what map
means but it's a small thing that's like
paper like pictures on earth and they
got the dwarf he got the map and Robin
yes yes and with the dwarf there was
another guy like like a taller and guy
human probably and this is what they're
doing here they're like ambushing
travelers but they really wanted they
had orders to get that dwarf in his map
where is the map you asked that yes
he doesn't really know it was taken to
the hideout to the cave
hmm so who who asked them to get this
map I'm gonna ask you to all four for
wits if you want yes if you don't mind
and let's go for an advantage okay and
there will be the last the last answer
so that's 11 okay that's enough
are you managed to understand that Clark
once the map
Clark is a bugbear and is the leader of
these guys bugbears are a different race
they're like taller stronger goblins so
they're usually like you know lead their
little tribes of water tribes Clark the
bug bear wanted the map he got the map
they also got the dwarf they took them
to the cave this is what you understand
from what's happening so they're but
they're still alive they didn't kill
them you didn't say are they still alive
you can't kill them he doesn't he
doesn't know we should go save them we
owe it to these guys who are potentially
dead and might have a lot of treasure to
save them and get their turn we owe it
to them to lay down our treasure
that's some mesm shady stuff man but uh
I mean I'll roll with y'all I'll see
what's over there cuz then like we got
now we have two objectives now transport
the stuff that we got and now we're
gonna take on this treasure as a side
quest almost what's on the way really
okay sure
is it though oh why is it there's that
sign post there's this a you wanted to
check so badly
well now that things have calmed down a
bit I'll go look at the signpost
so the signpost is pretty badly burned
no let's take Salukis you can still you
know read you can still read okay so
back where you where you're coming from
is the high road as you know took to the
west to the east so past the barricade
that you have destroyed is pendulum your
objective and then there's this other
direction where the Goblin wins and
there's written to tribal woods so you
understand that in this direction
deeper into the woods
[Applause]
also the wolf left behind some loot can
we loop the wolf take everything yeah
you guys can you're free to like yeah
tell around do whatever you want
so just to remember to Goblin maybe he's
gonna try to run away maybe it's gonna
true do something
oh yeah should we slice them up now that
we know everything that you can possibly
get like I mean I don't think I'd feel
so bad I feel like that's me he was very
helpful it was a lot of good information
say we let it go all right if you say so
but if I see him again
ain't no negotiating yo so please all
walk and really let all my friends with
us you said you said you said I'm free
yes yeah fine he walks you know it's
like carefully like keeping his eyes on
you guys because it's pretty scared and
then the second he thinks is out of
range it just starts running like
running for it
dashes around and I remember that he
might remember this moment of kindness
that we showed him maybe or whether you
were warned strength you don't know he
knows what's good for him he would just
hide forever II never see us again
there's a o side note I see a potion of
where that goblin was you can go get it
okay I'm go get that okay
thirsty dude all right is there anything
else around here that we should take
note of that we know one check that
campfire see if there's any Oh Rose a
ham ham yeah I like him you don't pawn
you ol exam quite Hanyu the event yeah I
was like a favor to do where did you
watch the point you I watch Ponyo like
two weeks ago I didn't know they had
movie theaters and I don't know I've
ever seen a movie theater outside of
France
[Applause]
[Laughter]
either you also been to frames
Oh No hey I'll learn how to be scrappy
from pond that's why it's why I'm real
harder now all right well I think it's
time we take this detour and go rescue
these guys I agree it's happening to do
it it's happening let's get it all right
guys see what maybe it'll be a dragon so
I hope the smell of tar and oil fills
the air oh I mean look at this taco you
cool I pull out my staff and excitement
okay
oh yeah well before you go to fart can I
take one of your wants you got to be
careful though if to want oh my I'm a
bit of a pyromaniac I've decided I've
seen just throw it on the ground well
you better get ready cause look ahead at
it oh my god do it
don't go burn this whole forest to the
ground no this looked like a trap though
you better burn it down before someone
else to do like one we're inside there
so what should you go first or should we
go first uh you guys you guys go first
you can set us on fire oh man all right
so I guess can we do a check to see if
we notice anything I'm dangerous outside
of the tell me what you're looking for
and also who's doing it any-any goblins
who has the best perception along so are
there any goblins waiting to ambush us
so we're it's this perception so
wherever you go at 12:00 so that's a
plus one so you're the best to do all
right yeah so I'm gonna be scoping out
to see if there are any goblins post it
up and if they have some kind of trap
set like I obviously see oil barrels all
around here so I also want to see if
they got like fire arrows or if they got
like torches one of ours
so essentially anything that looks
goblin made and it could be a building
or trap yes that's what you're looking
that is what I'm looking okay
this place look real sketchy that's when
you wits you have plus one yo let me get
it alright that is very good actually
that is very good okay I need to prepare
that really so essentially as you're
like looking you know gazing into the
distance trying to spot anything like
the Sun glimmers like shines on like a
metal object that you see and as you
like you know I try to look and spin or
your eyes you see a mine in the middle
in half you should see him you should
see it now where they at though the dead
there it is oh yeah yeah yeah there look
like oh I thought that looked like a
majority majority master something that
oh damn yeah guess it does a little bit
okay okay what do we want to do about
this we should go inside no I say we
tried set up a mine first
well right kills we should we should
move that barrel cuz okay it's interval
is enough to the box can every True
Religions for me real quick
sorry for interrupting by the way I'll
be no no I'm on a furlough dice roll oak
wait wait oh I top it lady g56 and so
you guys don't know I interrupted the
typo so I was approaching apologizing
for that five one six that's also great
so you guys aren't getting additional
insights alright well so can we you know
pick up the barrel and just roll it down
there yeah when he's like roll it into
the mine ooh we hope for that yes yeah
we can do that y'all think it's safe
doable I'm just gonna stand back a
little bit but yeah
that's probably smart as well I'll
handle it
what's the fire expert handle this so
what's the kind guys don't read take
this barrel we're gonna roll it into the
mine try like set it off okay all right
okay this is possible for you to step
out of the oil before you roll it cuz
what's that thing goes on man that's all
kinda like I'm gonna move it I need to
position it for okay okay I can't pick
it up or you can you can take it into
your inventory or you can just drag and
drop it a towers wherever you want it to
go k so rolling right there okay get out
of the way yeah there you go
sure yeah we're that taco you so smart
oh I gotta say yeah a little bit think
so you just for instance you can like
kick it and it starts rolling you can
tell me what how you want to do yeah I'm
gonna like kick it down yeah it's down a
hill
should be fun you're doing that yeah
okay so yeah exactly there's no strength
check for that so you do that and as you
can see do that well the barrel starts
rolling down the hill and well you know
sets move toilet so yeah it works
look at that yeah that's cool uh so you
got you got oh you know a little bit by
the explosion but you should be fine in
just a sec so the ground shakes when you
when do that absolutely absolutely
shakes and Battalion well thank guys
that was that was quite nice actually
and the fire should you know cleared out
anything dangerous so we should be just
wrong yeah exploring all right say we go
all right
Oh Chevy I see a burning chest was on
fire yeah hopefully I didn't burn the
items inside of you and hopefully
anything in there is totally fun okay
you don't even have to open it now cuz
it's a fish done it got busted up
reopened okay so in your back you see
you here to the cows like mooing and
like freaking out a little bit like
they're not happy about what she's
happened really how could their
disturbed oh yeah they're like totally
destroying like calm them down if they
don't run away how you want to do that
how you want to calm him down
oh no keep them a little nodule like mmm
complete-game grain hey can I give them
a ham oh yeah hey they might have I got
that hand you're gonna give the cows
that ham it's a little bit I mean see
I'm hungry too it doesn't really pay
attention I mean the hams workout is not
really interested in salvation i
cannibalized
notice this thing yeah it's a cow yeah
so you should have no moral obligation
to eating ham what else or world why I
used our own words to my intelligence
hmm objection that's the moral
objections well I mean I'm the one who
pushed the barrel so they probably don't
want to talk to me yeah they saw you do
that ah I'll feel just a little bit a
little bit again Oh him yeah I'll give
him a little chinchilla you know have a
treat all right y'all are doing good so
far pulling the wagon so okay so didn't
mean cow absolutely choose the moms
nothing giving him yeah but you know I
mean you know you can tell if he likes
it or not she she knows what she's
eating right now okay oh yeah she loves
anyone have a sleeping spell penny no
why would we need that you know then
calm down put him to sleep don't we need
wood carry that wagon yo I'm not gonna
take them into the Netherland
yeah sleeps be better if they just kind
of hung out and did something no keep
him tranquil down will not do that
haha I was gonna suggest a marijuana
I gotta I think there's all there's all
there's a lot of green up in here so you
guys can you guys gonna present a theory
but I don't feel free and really I'm a
scavenger I'm a look around and see if
there's anything Oh check out that chest
where's that chest over here oh oh okay
I see the show is locked it's locked
Oh bless it open what it's not made of
wood enough to just burn so where we are
it's pretty sturdy chest oh but you can
tell it's been here for a while
is it possible to like start like
knocking on it trying bust it open
that's right you can't there well
there's like several ways you guys can
do this you can try to pick the lock if
you have a actual lock picks I will give
you a plus two on the roll or you can
just like start hitting it like crazy
but you know that if there is my friend
connect yes yeah like their potions or
something well we don't do anything we
can't get anything unless there's
another way to open this without
damaging anything otherwise I'm gonna
start whaling on it now got any mean I
really got much in the way like blocked
a survey okay don't try and look pick
the lock
you can do this any tools sure it's just
that you it's it's gonna be much harder
is all yeah well if I fail a lot big
then I can just like start smacking it
oh I'm cool with that
all right so I'm trying our go
highlighting Lady Jane are you who's got
who's got the highest penis finesse is
gonna be what we're gonna use I should
have I don't what I should itself Jane
has a plus one all right I guess I'll
I'll come over and open this laugh
okay okay let's see what you got alright
and that's a nine plus one that's a ten
that's enough yeah it's a pretty pretty
rusty old lock and chest unlocks okay
and there was a trap inside Oh
so as you open as you open the chest
there's some sort of like mechanical
blogan that you know that that that like
fires a little dart a little poison dart
so I'm going to need you to roll the
nest again to see if you avoid it you
don't I'm very sorry you are taking and
go for the Tipton's so those are dice
for twelve plus two so that's going to
be 9 so you are getting nine damage and
you're gonna be poisons for a couple
turns I'm terribly sorry but I start
we're able to get in a little bit of
poison it's the second time you're not
gonna die from this it's just hard to
really this is how no I found some gold
other stuff in there that and there's a
spell of some kind restorations will
restore vitality of a target character
I'll go ahead and give that to taco oh
thank you
and I'll take the gold cause why not
he's still poisoned no it's it's okay
okay this curious poison the poison is
run its course
all right so let's let's just keep
exploring the Couser Couser fine
keep exploring the woods am take it
there's some vines to climb some red
vines now I thought I found a sounder
alright what is the sign set eager west
to the high road so that's behind you
and this way east to the tribal trail
yeah and tribal woods rather like into
the woods all right let's keep going -
into the woods
yeah let's yeah it's a skip this Shawn
Road oh you guys so you guys are done
with this area you don't want to go burn
oil yeah all right we good hey we set it
on fire we're good
that's again that's right you said him
by order okay all right whoa
okay CeCe governments and I'm going to
dip Derek dead after briefly following
the trail through the optimal octonal
sunny tribal woods you find yourself in
a small meadow I had a view of several
governments who haven't they haven't
noticed you yet Darren obviously peeking
through the trees as if waiting for
something to come out or as if afraid
that something might nearby it left and
guarded is the entrance to what have you
appears to be a natural
what are you going to do I wonder hey
dude so if they're waiting for something
they could be waiting for us because
yeah we did let somebody go earlier yeah
true true they're looking to the woods
don't look into beds me I think we
should wait in and see what happened
what are they waiting on I'm kind of ok
thoroughbred yeah me too
if this involves them killing themselves
that's fine I mean yeah I'm not tripping
so yeah ok wait a sec yeah mm-hm
let's go okay all right so the goblins
are there there's a bunch of them now
you can see you can see four so that
that could that might be difficult and
they're like excited you know and
they're medium afraid and waiting for
something to come out of the woods as
you wait wait for a bit and it as it
happens a bear emerges from the woods
and yeah and starts actually oh sorry
dipped it first are about that the bear
emerges from the woods and starts
attacking them ah yeah so the bear runs
towards the first goblin that sees it
chill can molds it no it's cute oh do
mattify the original divinity bear suck
so the goblins absolutely freaked out
and they run in that direction these
fools came running away what are you
guys gonna do
ah you have to don't have to fight you
control yes we can keep waiting until
like see the like a winds first the bear
or the I think we can just let again
there at the goblins are distracted by
the bear there they're fine they're
running off we can just go in the cave
and I have to worry about sneaking past
anything
wait where's this cave at though all I
see is yeah yeah I think we should just
go for the cake there is a goblin
running towards the cave and this this
one's pretty freaked out yeah right over
yeah so okay we'll take him out as we go
along all right cool I'm down I'll bet
you three gold at the bear wins
oh boy wages yeah um and I get why I
would bet on the bear but for the sake
of this I guess I got money on goblins
all right so three gold yeah all right
there pay up on me I definitely have
that much when you're done you can just
skip trip there okay
what's your sign for beautiful alright
echo alright we're gonna sneak by Oh are
we watching or you might as well go for
the cave oh snap alright okay alright
[Music]
so you guys are trying to be discrete
unit morale finesse or you just like
running it will be will be discrete you
want to be an ice cream yeah everybody
rolls for finesse please if you have a
MIDI fire and that's the time to tell me
for nine Jane's wife temple for quavo
all right tackle your your okay Lee
discreet oh you do not notice you
however the others it might be a
different outcome
okay get away through here are Jane
so the Goblin that was those before
wasn't it I had 10 I hit for that was 10
I had time plus 1/9 plus 1 okay so that
that's all right
the Ranger shoots the bear dip-dip damn
come on bear I'm doing a lot of goblins
dude I don't know if this bears in
surprise so the race was pretty tough
though he is tough
this guy here tries to like relocate to
shoot the bear and strings best actually
Wow the grunt friend what does it do
okay he's terrifying skips his turn but
the bear is not impressed it's really
not having a lot of fun yeah with this
he's got the back stabs on Daniel
this guy here keeps running to the cave
and enters it okay okay I need ice I
need to pick it up a little behind so
you start running along the sides don't
mind me goblins don't mind you get right
there
let's go ask okay oh so the Ranger
notices you like hello right you know
yeah he heard you and felt that you were
passing behind true
okay techo um down you've come across
what seems to be the entrance to a cave
screened by dense briar tickets from the
darkness inside a lone cold breath
carries the scent of ancient earth silt
fire smoke indicating what do you do
what's the plan
oh is this worse for all of you I mean
that's what he came for
that's why we came right we're going
inside let's go outside yeah we gotta go
inside we got together too so watch your
backs
watch the ceilings watching your flanks
what we gonna do this okay guys so
whenever you can enter the cave do it
and why I can complete the Copeland's
like they can fail take care I guess
we'll never know how our bed goes well
you'll find out when we come out if we
come out a true
yeah whichever one is a lot yeah unless
this cave has another end no I'm saying
toughy oh I'm sorry that wouldn't be
super helpful though is that our uh oh
yeah come on yeah yeah yeah it's true
so you're still shooting to bear is our
is our cargo gonna be fine
checked by okay so the Ranger notice to
you and hesitates yeah that's right
score up I bet I need to think about
just a second okay it's going to this
shoots you Oh
ain't nothing ain't nothing uh this guy
tries to run away from the bear oh and
bear is not his having none of it yeah
yeah honestly I want this bear to win so
these goblins don't even think about
trying to they don't even get the chance
to think about looking at her stuff cuz
these goblins do come out and we got our
stuff flying kind of chillin back there
there is a chance that they will
scavenge did we leave any like honey in
the cart bear can take there's still
left over can you don't have honey and
in the car side or for finding we got
brewskis and got han it's not worth
worrying about
it's bigger we more important things to
worry about
cuz that is the most important maybe
that was a goal reason we did this just
for that card but I will say that how we
be fine we bi
all right hopefully this gamma name keep
Sean he might keep I'll consider dat
quavo in TECO you're inside the cave
okay okay so let's just wait let's just
wait for Lady Jaye and see what she does
step up and make it yeah I just captured
with us yeah
alright that was no high school that
works for me
well played guys that's really nice okay
took a little damage you're entering the
cave okay Italy boy so if this is a bit
dark if you guys can't really see you
can hit tilde on your keyboard to
display the outlines of the characters
there you go yeah yeah that's cool is
that that that's that's gonna help you
see better okay so I'll just sorry I'm
just gonna pause the game there's like
goblins over in place if you're not
discrete they will probably see you I'm
just just letting you know and I just
want to show you a something that I have
that is right here Derek goblins a head
stooped drooling snarling angrily at
each other or at the darkness around
them their breath drawing short white
puffs in the cold humid air of cave they
go about their business sharpening their
weapons petting their wolves absently
chewing dried meats or staring into
space how are you gonna handle this
there's a bunch of Munem there yeah
there is a lot I think I think I know
how we're gonna play this just gonna you
know try and chill the shadows not try
and stir anything unless me I think
they're gonna notice this eventually
though everyone do you think I want to
get the jump on them if they brought the
other guys here to live there must be a
reason they have them alive so you could
say hey we're here with the other we're
here with the dwarf and the human you
guys brought earlier okay
I say we're here we're friends we're all
together we're saying that to the
goblins yeah what thing I do is I get a
clearing we're declaring war on them
basically not well maybe maybe they kept
them alive but we're here is so we tell
them why we sing group which is telling
we're here for the door and that map
yeah and I weren't what's the end goal
of saying that though
to find out what the dwarf in the what
this map is all about say that we're
here to pick up the map for the next
stage where it will try to remove them
yeah oh I feel you actually we're the
you know we're the delivery people
there's here to get here the here to get
the guys oh man so can you refrain that
for me so I understand what the plan is
hi zip yeah I had to think of this as we
were going along so we're going to try
to tell the goblins that we're here to
pick up the door from the human they
captured we're here to get the map we're
the next step so we're the reason that
they were we are hired by the person who
hired them to capture them and so they
need to deliver them to us and we'll go
take them on to the next part they did a
really good job we'll pay them well
we're here to deliver their payment
whatever you know we'll think what you
do remember because the golden said so
that their leader is a bugbear called
Clark you remember that you incorporate
that into her yeah but Clark he we're
sitting here to talk to Clark
oh so we could go meet him yeah mmm say
that yeah three months core we'll know
what today we avoid if we mentioned card
oh no we have to obviously know
something which is Claudia should be
expecting us he's not he's an idiot
before you guys do anything you see
who's who's first taco are you see
running and in front of you and then he
disappears into the shadows the two of
the Goblin mystic and the other the
other got knocking I think the second
goblin didn't enter the cave but the
first goblin that ran away from the bear
cuz I you hear that that's an echo of
his voice you know died down somewhere
in the darkness so the goblins are
actually looking at him and laughing you
know and that's what you're here so
they're not really paying attention
right
okay just letting you know so we have a
potential sneak opportunity something we
don't really know where we're going
there's a lot of goblins so we're gonna
say we here for claw Clark okay okay so
then our goal is to be like okay like
we're here to talk to Clark yeah deliver
the guys will we'll take them to the
next step yeah so we can walk freely
amongst this cave in hi all right I feel
that I'm gonna try there was a
misunderstanding earlier and we didn't
get to explain ourselves before you had
to kill everybody yeah that happens we
just killed something always like ain't
nothing we don't want that to happen you
know I do they know we killed they're
always looking probably yeah probably
snitches but uh yeah that's helpful oh
you guys do it make it happen okay it's
really your choice how you guys want to
do this right we just want to run
straight it's your plan so I think you
should take lead
yeah well just write a new key forget to
do it I'll follow I'll follow your lead
wherever you want to go late yeah okay
we're spot so you guys are not really
trying to be discreet or anything no
should we ask where Clark is the
government seen you though there's like
what really they see you and start like
aiming them their bows in your direction
and I'll climb up here you guys know
okay he grabs you up
he grabs your like you essentially
wishes sting say his breath it's
terrible it's is done takane things it's
vulnerable
do you resist like he's like breathing
it literally yeah you know everything do
you resist okay like you don't know what
you're doing
okay you don't can I go up there and
back her up well this is happening
really quickly okay so I'm just gonna if
you follow me I'll roll for strength
with Lady Jane okay that's a four so you
don't manage to to use this you are
being like grabbed essentially go ahead
not cool all right come on I'm gonna go
up there and try and break this up real
quick so we can talk to them and let
them know yo mm-hmm where Clark at okay
let me go up there okay get your hands
off my girl Britt so how are you are you
gonna do that are you going to let me
like some karate chop light yeah not to
hurt him though just be like yo back up
yeah yeah Oh forearm
yeah those bows yeah okay I'm thinking
all right let's let's do this please
rule for yes gonna be strength to same
strength to strength just do it just
wrong like sit on these fools real quick
yeah just do it do Oh 11 11 that works
that's that's more than what they have
they have the Ranger is eight the grunts
has has 12 but the Renta crunch was not
grabbing okay so okay so you managed to
like push them back run you know so they
you you made a little space here so so
that's that's that's good
however or they're really really like
like and they really get it this is if
you guys want to do anything or say
anything now's the time yeah so hey take
us apart that's all in it yeah take us
to glory that's what you say Jane all
right this is gonna be whit's please be
convincing please Oh what you got what
you got 2000 see Carlo oh there's B did
I live for these moments was this
fortunate for them because we about the
what they asked
oh wow whoa all right the Goldman first
the Goblin is you know days but your
beauty it's like it's like he did not
realize that house he was like
Avenue but the intensity of your your
eyes and just oh wow and you smell
wonderful I know you're not wearing it
perfect before him get out that you're
not stinking smells wonderful it's all
relative you say take us to cleric in
the most delicate voice I said that's
the clown I says yes ma'am I'll take you
to Clark then and the other grunt goes
like what are you doing oh no what are
you doing and and then I stood a some
shut up just let them mean come with me
can't you see that they're very
important humans or whatever they are so
you guys he's gonna take you to Clark
and there's gonna be your guide in this
tour cool
oh that was absolutely so you guys are
free to fool him okay sorry for the
earlier misunderstanding I just had to
flex on y'all real quick okay then all
right here I need to UM look at my map
so I don't know if we can if we can do
that if I can have a minute oh yeah yeah
I need to look at the Mount cuz usually
players don't even do it
this is never this is never what happens
awesome sad this miss Colin doesn't know
where he's going like the first time
this ever happened so this is wonderful
I feel like you didn't trust me going
into this in obviously this worked out
perfectly
this is my this is my plan all along is
really cool I that was quite amazing
that I gotta say milady
alright that was like that's a flag
right there y'all but not without me
Ricky okay I feel this is still gonna
end very badly I'm really just hoping it
ends with all of us 9 we're just holding
back the impending dude
yeah so the Goblin is walking towards
and ended in this direction every time
he's doing like mean another goblin
they're gonna be look there's like
humans behind you what are you doing and
every time he's there the important
people for Clark so just stop it
are you do you guys falling yeah if you
guys trying
you're just like oh we don't be sick yet
we're here for some specific yeah rock
it out push our Charlotte alright
alright okay I need a minute to set that
up I'm not more than a minute though how
how y'all feeling about this will tense
yeah yeah this is a terrible idea I
don't know why you listen
alright oh man so well the Goblin is
like taking you deeper and deeper into
the oil everybody roll forwards please
real quick alright you all here
fantastic sixteen fourteen fifteen
that's that's really good you're here
wolves barking like bird and then you
hear like like cheering okay
essentially this is ready here so the
Goblin walks and just keeps walking
essentially why you don't know where
he's going and he stops there
and looks in this direction and I need
to pause it real quick to show you
something guys ahead jumping and
clapping and shouting in the orange glow
of torches goblins are excitedly
watching two walls fight yeah cheers and
yells echo around the cavernous hall
sometimes they throw dirt or small rocks
of them encouraging the animals to kill
one another or booing when the chosen
champion gets bitten what's the plan
well announce ourselves again like we
have an emissary already to help out for
us yeah just I say cheer with him I'm
down the bog ready I'm not down with
that I'm pretty sure that I'm into
betting on people fighting so I feel
like this is we have a raiment with a
reason to be here oh yes got that real
quick both we can do both you can cheer
and I know it no there's no cheering no
cheering Oh cheering Oh cheering all
right guys we're just gonna
play it cool man all right play cool
don't you if you if you try and share
with them we look like a trial so like
the wolves are fighting and biting one
another home and it's a s it's terrible
and the other goblins are like totally
Tallulah cherry monkey want to make a
bet here and say we don't you tell some
money you guys want to make a bet you
guys always do something no you know
we're not gonna bet on animal pit
fighting yeah that's not what we're here
for is why before if we would be here to
break it we can come here later
break it up savages so what's the plan
you guys are no God we got to get to the
gotta get to with you guys yeah sorry to
call our yes right all right Clark kid
yeah okay um you guys wanna take a look
around you guys gonna do it I want to
ask this guy how much money they're
putting down sorry Laura
coming I want ask him how much money
like they're exchanging hands for this
guy's so he sees you he's like very
surprised it's like a dwarf in my cave
what's happening so he draws his weapon
and any and so the other guy and the
other goblin goes no no no no no no no
that's is they're never they're good
they're friendlies friends don't just no
eat uh what's your question I was just
like hey I think this is a really rad
operation you guys go in here and I
would like to know yo like can i what
kind of money is exchanged your hands
like how lucrative is this what do you
did you use the word operation mmm
probably probably not oh you want to
rephrase that really like what you guys
are doing here
and I'm just curious uh how much money
you guys make off this Oh
okay I'm thinking about maybe doing this
myself on the side
yes of starting an animal fighting pit
are you yeah I mean you're talking about
the dog about to fight it specifically
the fighting can you want you want to
roll intelligence to get that
information you have a plus one yeah all
right go ahead that's eleven that's
that's that's a lot so essentially you
okay you understand that
well they capture wolves into into them
into into the woods essentially but they
take them really young and then they do
that they like torture them into
becoming their pets essentially the
answer is from I take them older because
I figured like they're already trained
that's that makes a lot of sense like
and love it young you also hear you also
learn from this guy that somewhere in
this cave there's like a kennel where
they like keep the Wolves chains and
they like feed them feed them you know
and they torture them and feed them meat
from from voyageurs from our sorry
voyagers travelers to like train their
smell and taste so they think they're
delicious essentially so like they have
got this old version and this is part of
their training to like fight one another
essentially okay okay so it although it
happens regularly that well some of the
wolves died because it's so much fun
does that answer your question
yeah very much yeah so he's looking at
at his friend and they are exchanging
looks really puzzle that what is
happening and yeah so your guide just
like ways for you and take it down to
whatever you want let's continue on geez
Oracle you really stirred things up
there for a minute
messed up for you though I will know we
know how do I give all this party
congratulations we know that they run a
very tight operation savage I free let
the cages go cause some if we need to
custom
No yeah but then doesn't it know that I
think they might vote for us
Oh for us specifically because the
goblins are chillin there and they're
not doing nothing
often so I'll think about I'll think
about it people stopped Iraqi all right
so the bellman walks and your climb
stairs and he's this chlorophyll looks
at you and waits I went to you guys do
all right let's go in
yeah it's gonna work this where Clark is
uh yeah well do you ask that hole too
late now
yeah let's roll it it okay sorry I need
to set that up okay real quick and dear
please are the Goblin keeps walking I'm
sorry that's wrong direction
wrong direction oh and and I see that
climbs that ladder cuz that's what it
does and he announces something that
first I'm going to show you okay you
guys ready yes yeah okay gosh upon
entering the room you see a tall bugbear
which is a creature that I described
earlier equipped with a
primitive-looking mace Saxon crates of
looted provisions are piled up around
him and the creature seems to be
counting them all the while I think a
wolf sitting beside him the animal
starts growing in direction the burglar
turns to face you so we explained that
we're here for the human in the door
from the map so the plan I got you you
only 20 which was absolutely beautiful
know it was you Jane James already just
lady Jane did lady lady Justin lady
Justin I roll a 28 it was absolutely
beautiful but and it got you through the
cave absolutely safely but I'm gonna ask
you to like convince this guy you know
there's gonna be like a new role okay
yeah just laying you know me okay Clark
turns to face you and the wolf is not
quite happy about you being here so the
government says these humans said they
wanted to talk to you
and what happens next
so now I roll to talk right yes you
could tell me what you want what you
want to say well I want to I want to
explain we're here for the human and the
dwarf and the map and we would like you
to give them to us
that is so risky man yes okay that is
going to be let's let's do it again
so I'm sorry I was looking at the
goblins stats so that's intelligence
just like last time let's do it
hublife 13 so that's a 14 let me check
their stats see how convincing you are
so Clark is not so brilliant the Ranger
is already convinced no matter what the
wolf is a wolf
you've got plugs attention he looks at
there at the ranger it doesn't
understand doesn't really understand
what's happening like what what do you
mean like what do you mean you you come
to get these guys the dwarf is not here
all we've got is the human and also
you're coming to get them but for whom
for your boss but my boss told them to
keep them here it change of plans they
you know things change there has been a
change of plans and where are the plan
changers or the delivery people okay
that changing plan so that is a pretty
heavy life so what I'm going to do is
that card right now is going to roll for
intelligence so here it says that Clark
has 10 but that's not true Clark is 7
it's really stupid so I just like set it
up so that's a it's a -2 intelligence so
if Clark buys it that's great
she doesn't gain he doesn't
it's a baby that smells - okay and you
did it how you did it how much doesn't
buy it doesn't get invite so he's gonna
ask you one thing one simple thing okay
then
a rather oh here do you know what's the
name of my boss large bar here for your
brother bar ha ha no - please don't say
that day is it
how are you guys gonna handle this uh
what it's a new move the name of your
boss is our friends sword you will well
I think we should try for intimidation
now this is working we hope it never
loses oh yeah I'm swole but this boy so
he's not listening to reason
we just go straight to in Timoney have
one more chance to listen to reason
well I don't think we're gonna guess the
name or what if he doesn't know what the
name of these bars what if what if I say
like yo mean quavo I'm your boss you're
looking at a boss right now I don't
think he would buy that it's a human and
true uh-huh I got swag over there that's
right we tryin you want to try looking
freaky
maybe hmm look cuz then I don't think
look if you look under here he has a
wolf - goblins as a goblin posted up as
well I don't think that he's like going
to be intimidated because he has so many
things like backing him up so ask him
does he not recognize his boss who is
standing right behind me I'm speaking
for his boss and that's is ruthless
right here okay
yeah all right I like it I like it like
I am human but please live carding isn't
too bright so I'll be like yellow you're
looking at your boss right now mmm so
like low-key Undercover Boss stuff right
now I would like you to all four that's
gonna be what's your trying to like
trick him yes you have any persuasion
anything at all this isn't a personality
civil abilities you
really have any persuasion sadly all
right let's just let's try it then Iran
what to tell you let's try this is what
we're gonna roll it this right down the
street
12 so that what would that be a 13 from
that's a 13 for you sorry
okay he looks at you a really eyes of
you I see you I'm sorry up and down
I'm flexing - so huh it's got seven
intelligence which were pretty stupid
the thing is and you don't know that but
now I'm gonna tell you I was he's gonna
buy it I think he's never seen his boss
I think I never met him so he says
you're the black spider here the black
spider oh oh
so the Goblin right next to him like
kind of like like you know like relaxed
fire really oh and go girls Clark goes
and was like a bit sad though for some
amazing disappointed not really you
don't know didn't I really don't know it
boy I got a problem there was quite
something though but he's not it's not
aggressive he's not aggressive but what
I'm saying is that he's giving you the
benefit of the doubts I don't know
fifth day yeah you can say that in
English you know why yeah not totally
convinced he's gonna keep an eye on you
but that was that was good it was good
enough to get us off the hood for now
okay exactly so Ford out for now it's
good enough but yeah guys here to get
those the scroll so what's the plan are
you so we're we're gonna go grab the
human so like we said we're here to grab
the key one get the map when we get out
of here yeah well we're not even will
won't bother you guys maybe is done
wolves for me pet won't we'll see so see
Clark explains that the dwarf and the
map are not there and he like actually
you should know that you wanted it to be
sent to the castle
please roll for with
trumple fastened on me mmm
600 yeah I was like okay hmm
yeah well you know Clark your plug is
really off convinced to sit are you in
posters are you trying to trick me and
[Music]
turnips or a dress oh my bad y'all
that's those people though is that was
quite something I got a say so the
Ranger like looks at chloric and not
sure what to do how are their the black
spider or not the black spider and this
guy jumps down the ladder and starts
running in a direction Clark goes you in
posters you tricked me and run stores
quavo and hits you Ripper is a dog so
isn't just gonna buy k2 Jane cuz that's
what he does and he's going to be really
mad right now
and he gets away you guys can do it you
guys can fight back or you can try stuff
are you loving them I do not have
ah what's y'all feeling we're gonna
fight this we don't throw down Oh throw
ahead doesn't think we'll survive
clariah strong as hell oh dude he's a
little three we're level one yeah I we
if we fight straight up like um I'm
tough and I'm tough as hell but like I
don't think we're gonna get out of this
one where is the human they're not uh
can you say they're not here hello the
dwarfism here for the humans here the
door for the mat partner yeah but humans
hello let me try and save Li you try
like run away when you find the human
Wow once we do and then what well what
do you think the black spider would do
in the situation if we can convince him
otherwise
are we like full-on battle mode like
yesyes well he's whooping my ass right
now so like I'm not it can't be like yo
what are you doing on black spider yo
it's like well oh I'm beating on you
right now so uh oh whoa uh make that
what if
I wonder if he's like super slow since
it's like really big and we can like
just finesse around and like just keep
running
pick up the human and it's like kind of
zigzag our way out of here you don't see
any human this in this room right you
would need to take a better look but at
first sight you did not notice anybody
else right is it possible that a human
would be in this gray area further down
this particular room like in this gray
area right you can't it be like yeah it
could be possible but you can't tell
really
that's true oh man this is this is quite
the pickle with y'all feelin we can run
out the baton set stuff on fire that's
real good
oh right let's look at our environment
exact this is some exploding barrels a
lot of fire we're at this wall is one up
there one up here okay so we got a wolf
two goblins and Clark look what if okay
it's my turn I'm gonna try and see if I
want to try my knock down and see if it
knocks down it's got a lot of physical
armor okay might not work you might have
to hit him first forget you're like that
all right what if we try and fight this
out
alright alright let's do this that's try
it alright I'm gonna encourage y'all
creases and fills craters maximum piece
of armor a 4/5 okay so I'm gonna
encourage you all if we can do this
believe it okay and then I'm gonna get
some physical armor on myself
because I am kind of get whupped
otherwise right and I will did you just
I think you fortified your 45 card it's
okay it's okay it's absolutely oh it's
absolutely okay okay I can I can handle
this on my side I wanna say that's okay
your character will not do that it would
not really make sense
I like a 4 to 5 like yo look see I got
your back
sorry I need a second to uh to do that
down I'll give you this one okay there
you go
cool horn stealing got four okay so I
have two more AP and I think been a can
i poison him hmm saving throws magical
poison
oh snap poison blocked my magic yeah
your your own as in like did you poison
like yeah I school it worked yeah he
poisoned the dog I know I didn't poison
Clark though yeah he said I think I said
he was immune
I am so I'm gonna who can I like can I
put my shield up oh I know I need to I
should have put my shield oh there's
nothing I can do cheeese a minute poison
and I can have my turn with one AP and
then oh yeah you will that's right okay
so I'm gonna turn hopefully I can stick
this out okay fire
alright tech oh well top that makes tape
bread do that I can do that and
like this is gonna set us on fire as
well I'm trying to not do quavo is gonna
come up I'm standing pose Eli Cohn's
that was all right I wasn't able to get
the one up there I thought it was gonna
go over the arc I'm not sure what that
did that was really bad yeah I'm not
sure that worked
no yeah it is you're a terrible shot hey
yeah you are a terrible wizard thank you
look I can really get that guy up here
no kale am you can you can climb that
letter by the way okay
that would make it walk the fire button
let's go yeah oh I try petrified Clark
these guys and to sort it say can I yell
at the the Craig mall ranger and the
goblins around us and tell them that
they're making a huge mistake
and if they help you their bosses has
already made his he's already made this
mistake
he's fight he has touched their boss he
has touched the spider but they still
have a chance to redeem themselves it
may help us kill mm-hmm if they help us
kill all right then then we'll let them
live otherwise we're gonna murder
everybody in this cave hmm okay I'm sure
she'd be really convincing with that
however however there's one last thing
that I want to do it's going to just
take a second is that the Goblin that
you had convinced earlier of course he's
joined the fight is like standing right
there
but he's still fascinating but you're
going to eat and everything like musk so
yeah that's right
so I was like go ahead let's be kind of
it saying this gonna be with so that is
the one oh that didn't really work
and so yeah best ask I can do is is that
the Ranger that used to be your friend
I'm puzzled and not sure what to do what
do you do I have to follow up on that I
can't do nothing and you for scream like
so I'm gonna use my decaying touches a
necromancer on Clark here okay go ahead
yeah it's the best physical are more
decayed touch little skate holes no
Clark is really tough yeah just remember
me sit down that is you're gonna have
any effect yeah he's a beer belly though
mm-hmm no I'm gonna move out of the way
I'm gonna go sit down on the bench nice
cool you gonna do that
yeah just a show that I am Not Afraid of
this situation so this is okay so you're
not like surrendering it's like a
notification oh my god you got wood oh
yeah yeah ah you took an attack of
opportunity from Clark uh yeah this is
not going I don't feel like that was
very intimidating
that's after all this is not going well
tackle you're getting shot oh no damn oh
this guy so this guy's she's in fire so
he first is gonna like try and get out
of it but he's not burning cos got
magical armor and it's going to ask me
to shoot tackle oh and your diet well I
was getting to some resurrection spells
but yeah sorry can't really do that
anymore
okay so Clark turns to face you know and
a man I'm quoting Bodil don't mess with
me man
sorry like here reasonably you know I
don't I don't know how I can I can stop
this from happening that that so Ripper
is poisoned and yeah just like out of
habit ice
helps is his master oh and we done son
I'm very sorry about that that is a
party wipeouts that's a horrible way to
die
uh-huh Wow okay so essentially what
happened is that I'm going to need some
time to like set up what happens next
okay guys okay okay so essentially you
are so you've been badly wounded this is
really this didn't really go well
essentially what happens is that she has
it dead sorry to somebody and you guys
have been I've been badly wounded and
you guys have been dragged throughout
the cave like so I'm preparing this it
takes it takes a little bit of time and
[ __ ] I don't know where you are equate
Oh what happened to you oh I got
obliterated man you did yeah you did got
blasted oh yeah I'm going to just put
that real quick and so okay so you guys
[Music]
so you guys wake up pretty much naked
and your your your your gear and
and weapons were taken away from you and
you wake up in this life
humans cave and it's really cold and
you're also sadly you're badly wounded
and this is how it's going to happen
I just need an additional second to
prepare this and then I'll be right with
you sorry guys this is a typically the
situations that yeah really really
interesting and that's that
the does yeah so maybe if we hadn't
gotten through the cave without killing
anybody we could have leveled up a
little got stronger while I was thinking
and I'm nearly done not as tough as I
thought I would well that was that was a
big bug bear though that was really it
was really big that fool got swallows
[Applause]
and you wake up in that humid cave and
it's really cold you winded and you've
been dropped here essentially
alright so as you can see so you're in
that that weird cave and now I'm going
to give you a little bit of what's
happening if you give me just a second
you have reached or rather in your case
you have been taken to a cave that seems
to be used as a kennel wolves are kept
here they're changed leading to iron
rods driven into the base of stalagmites
this is what you were told that you know
about this is their knowing at bones and
aren't paying you into any attention for
now three actually it's written too but
I think I've placed three true
governments are sleeping there by there
doesn't seem to be any other passage in
this room at first types of dead end
what are you gonna do now huh still got
my ham yeah throw the ham yeah I'm
definitely not gonna draw my blade no
more man you don't have a blade so yeah
well I would draw my hands I'm full
hands yeah we might as well try to make
friends with the are all we are you guys
wanna make friends I know I was directly
we didn't want to put them into fighting
pits hi we've always liked the free on a
set them free are the end goal here is
to get them to friend us if you want
this thing is that you're gonna yeah
you're gonna have to find some food
because we're doing you don't really
like have it anymore because yeah your
stuff was kind of taken away that's
great there I'm very very sorry about it
like that great cuz know what okay no I
didn't know how to pair what was like
pairs one pair for for wolves sounds
great don't think wolves like yours I
felt a teleportation spell you did yes
that's pretty serious yeah ken is having
your man you gotta get out of see second
to it Dan look on my look at Mike I
gonna drop them I can pick so it up and
I can like drop
I'll go down my face okay guys hey look
at that definition of my abs okay this
bull does not skip like that you also
not have not spotted you and the goblins
are sleeping as you can see on the other
side okay cool
so you can you guys can like take a look
around really you can tell me what
you're looking at for instance you can
you can try anything you want
essentially you can take a look for
instance I said that the room was a dead
end but you can take a look at the walls
maybe there is more to it than it seems
especially especially I'm sorry were you
were you guys woke up there's much
asleep in dangers that's right one of
these glowing things oh god orange and a
carrot are you trying to be discreet
Tekel uh yeah you should probably really
better one second to account the fact
that you're you don't have any shoes on
okay I'm sorry real quiet so you're real
quiet this is gonna be finesse by the
way just fourteen totally works your
shadow your do what if I try
pickpocketing movies there will be
another role though you're trying to
pickpocket these guys that's so yeah
good luck alright no can I look towards
the will see what what situation they
have going on
so the wolves are knowing it bones and
essentially like like eating stuff that
is there they're chained so they're not
unless you start like provoking them or
like being you know aggressive they're
not going to come after you they could
see you and start barking though I found
a pear carrot and an orange do you think
wolves like any of those three things
no I think we have a taste for blood
what if we kill one of the goblins and
throw them to the wolves
so they get a taste for the gun where's
my teleportation spell to teleport him
into the pits oh snap
yellow smart let's do that yeah this
guy's really smart doesn't yeah
yeah get them get look as I said a
little bit of a revenge okay I'm gonna
try doing that all right now do all
y'all got brilliant minds make the
happen see if I can do this I'll let you
do it okay pick it up and I can't Jen I
can't move them over there apparently I
can't I mean there's not enough now it's
like I'm yeah can you try to maybe stand
a little farther from them from them
yeah yeah if not if it doesn't work I'll
allow it because I think it's a good
idea there's no reason for you you
should be able to see through the art
yeah you know I mean the arch sorry you
notice that there's a barrel oil barrel
yeah what if we light these fools up
let's take a lob yeah
now it's okay I think that's a very good
idea so what's gonna happen is that I'm
gonna take the I'm going to take the
teleportation scroll from your in
century all right
so you can cancel the spell casting No
Allah and I consider it used which one
of the goblins would you like to tell
her actually try to work this guy right
here the guy in the middle is the guy
closest to the pit of bones you got it
so it works dispel dispel works huh and
you throw this guy
so where do you throw in what side like
left side right three walls adjustable
there are three wolves yeah all right so
you throw throw the Goblin there the
Wolves so of course he the guy the guy
wakes up and and just like you know he
has a moment of where am i of confusion
and the Wolves start attacking and
immediately pops and they they literally
eat him alive
this is really what
happening and the tools like absolutely
we start like like devouring him however
so that work so you're watching I don't
know but how you feel about this in
horror or satisfaction as the Wolves
literally rip apart the poor gobbling
screams you know and they're like really
rip his arms and however this wakes up
the two other guys that was uh I mean
yeah that was of course to be expected
to do what did we want to get out of
that get the wolves a taste for eating
gobbling yeah yeah so can we sneak up on
the wolves in are you guys are hiding
are you guys trying we're hiding you
guys hiding so this might break the
chains of the wolves we set them on the
other set them on the other guys yeah so
I'm gonna need you all first to a role
for Phoenix see how well you are hiding
and I would like you guys please if you
don't mind to describe to me how you're
hiding you know what I mean like are you
like crouching or you know okay
I'm backed up against these rocks over
here just kind of deck with it to six
let's finesse by the way if I did not
mention that so if you have any any
bonus or anything that's eight so that's
what's not so great guys and these guys
have yeah the Rangers of fourteen wits
which is their passive detection
therefore if they come looking for you
or looking in your direction they will
see you immediately
for now they're going to take a look at
what happened to their friend and
they're pretty freaked out so they run
towards towards you and they see you
indeed Wow haha I'm going to ask for
okay
so what's gonna happen I'm going to be
transparent with you on this because
it's a lot of fun this Ranger that is
standing right in front Jane I'm gonna
make it so that if the dice a so I lets
the Ranger from earlier okay I'm gonna
say that for instance if I roll 16 or
higher on this dice is your friend
that's a four oh very sorry
so this guy just like what what what
what and and engages you
gages combat but again do think that you
can you can do whatever you want you
guys can try to talk to the other guy
however is not there yet is very
surprising like like I'm trying to like
you can get his bow whatever
your turn do remember however that you
are badly wounded yeah that would be bad
if anything should happen you still have
your skills but if the skills require
weapons you will not be able to use them
que esta plan uh walls my turn right now
I am man I just all I got us I'm just
gonna courage you all like yo this is
not this is not an optimal situation but
this is it is the least I can do for
y'all so let's encourage everyone okay
we can do this yeah that you did a
little bit of everybody okay yes and I
am going to oh it's the least I can do
is I'm gonna get up here with a lady
Jane speedfan yeah I'm gonna try and
poison this fool or I can fortify a
fortify Lady Jane it's the last thing I
can do for your girl I got your back
alright echo ah be smart like this is
what you yeah you know this is what you
do usually you're someone you do smart
things I feel like breaking the chains
of the woods could potentially set them
on the goblins but they probably still
want to eat us so I don't know if that's
the best you have any spell do you still
have your spell's right yeah I have some
fire
I got oil for setting stuff on fire I
got my petrify still I have to get up
close to him how much ap does your
petrified
mm takes about two but I won't have
enough if I have to get all the way up
close to one
what's at last at jeopardy I don't think
we there's much else we can do
might as well set the Wolves free if we
die we die try and set the Wolves free
we died setting them free all right I
did Wow okay with that it's you do
realize that if you come too close they
will try to eat you as well well is
there a way I can like I burn the chains
off with my fireman well those are like
even though it's like old iron probably
rusty and everything you as a fireman
you know that it would take like real a
little bit of time till I bring them to
like melting fries you know Oh
i'ma fix wolves you guys can try to
convince the Goblin you guys to try to
intimidate him I don't know how but you
could try I could try and convince him
that I can teleport him too oh yeah like
see what happened to you homie like we
did that I can do that I can do it again
so I know yeah oh let's try that okay
you try that I can I can allow you to to
use intelligence or wits for this like
be brutal illogical let's do
intelligence because there have more
that you got it so do you have any money
fire anything I got 13 on you I told
it's all right it's a plus-one oh let me
check how much that's saying that might
be okay cuz this guy has got four okay
you know I mean this guy is really
stupid okay uh it I'm thinking okay he
hesitates it looks it looks at you and
he looks at as he has bits and pieces of
his friend the wolves are so like
ripping offices or arms and everything's
disgusting any hesitates it's the best
second different then you can you can
still do something but if you do attack
him though the chances are that you
again
oh I'll wait it out
Jane uh I guess again I'll talk to him
see if I can convince him
is this the business our friend earlier
was this the one that we celebrate no
yeah if it had been your friend you
wouldn't acted completely differently so
say that we showed you mercy earlier if
you could've at least for us so one you
set free I did not think of that hmm
doctor tell them it's true actually what
if the one you set free is the one you
threw into wolves don't oh oh I don't
know we do all of the same I don't know
but that's that's a good thing okay sis
I did not think of that uh it's not the
one who said you've set free but you can
use that you can do something with this
maybe we'll let him know like we fought
these guys earlier we set one of your
friends free and we threw the old
allegedly legit interesting okay show
show us a revolt beg for mercy
yeah beg for mercy and maybe we'll spare
your life go ahead I'm gonna ask you for
it you did intelligent last time those
you want to try it again or you want to
try wits your intelligence is better so
if you want to like nails you in
telescope yeah
that's 14 yeah that's that was your your
your argument is valid you know it's
it's it's logical also also even though
that you guys are naked you seem to be
mages and of your three ends guy is all
alone and also is heard about your your
active grace from earlier that you've
let's his friend go so he's not gonna
put away the bow just now but he asked
you what do you want I just want to go
home really yeah get out of here we let
we failed almost all our quests this is
a mistake let's go we need to get back
up we have a we have our cars upstairs
it was just a why don't you
misunderstanding like you I'm gonna go
home eat a nice steak I bet you do too
let's just you know it's all good right
it's all good the time to tell 14 was
not so bad though and this guy has four
so it would make sense I guess that I'm
thinking aloud that he [ __ ]
it's not gonna go alright alright then
like what's the optimal path out of here
we'll just dart and we won't even bother
you guys again you never see us again
you'll never see us again
oh it's difficult though I'm trying to
to have a situation to make sense of
course okay you can end your turn
whenever you're ready Jane and what's
going to happen is that the Goblin is
going to acknowledge well your your
valid argument and not going to shoot
but it's going to is going to keep his
eyes on you to see what you do and then
you can just only hope that it doesn't
really draw the connection between his
dead friend that the wolves are eating
and you guys because he was sleeping so
whatever you do do it fast
please so if we could look around see if
there's a an exit maybe that we didn't
notice earlier mm-hm
so there is some light coming out of
here yeah there's that path right there
so what I'm going to do is you guys can
take a look around but it's gonna be
difficult because this guy's really
breathing down your neck you know what I
mean so just make a run for the sunlight
here you wanted I'm up do you want to
try that yeah okay I go you guys knew I
could climb oh yeah yeah okay tap that
down very well done um sorry I need I
need just a second alright so yeah
there's a crack in the north wall after
closer inspection you notice a natural
chimney there seems to be enough space
for you to get inside there's noise
coming from the bowl so that could work
okay let's climb up let's go up yeah get
out yeah let's we have no other choice
just for sake of clarity there was
another exit at the other end of the
room that you have seen because it was
not it was not hidden so you have you
have two choices okay you can like go
through here or go through the main
the cave that was there sunlight see I
see I see sunlight I'm good yeah it's
that I don't want to feel now I don't
want to like run into any other example
yes with you sure yeah oh yeah so you
see my body in the game I could climb
there alright okay
very well then yes okay so I need a
moment to set that up but it will not
take long tap tap tap down I feel like
we come out someplace that's not full of
sunlight it was only ambient light as it
was difficult so you all managed to
actually like climb back up uh all the
way without hurting yourself and you
arrived here and just seems familiar
it's Clarke hostile fire oh [ __ ] they're
still fighting these idiots sorry funny
killing themselves yeah because it's
just don't worry about it
oh this guy's red but wrong this one
this yeah so what's the plan guys don't
mind the Goblin that's there he has no
idea that you guys are here with red is
there any other way to keep climbing
sorry you could you could you could very
well leave it you could you could leave
- or where you guys have you know keep
going up with it going up
you cannot go keep going up as much
could you could you could go downwards
yeah or could we jump into the water and
the water would just take us out hmm
that's a good idea actually follow the
river
full the river yeah yep you just jump at
the water the river takes a sound stream
there's some barrels it looks like in
these barrels
it's like it leads to nothing hobbit
style mmm what we just go up to Clarke
him like y'all look we're naked nails
let us go man I would I would lie down
okay
can you guys take a look around real
quick for wits just just to see if you
notice something 1970 you guys notice
scoping the chests that are there and
the crates and all
so you know what I'm saying is that she
gave me just a second to set that up
sorry sorry sorry I'm just trying to say
that real quick for you guys and as you
open the chest I'm sorry the crate that
is there this is your gear actually that
has been stashed here when you guys were
taken or rather as you understand now
dropped down this shaft to the kennel
for to be eaten oh cool all right
you guys can yeah go go ahead pleasure
does that still work there can we can we
just jump in the water and try to swim
so yeah I was gonna absolutely I was
going to answer that
so you do you do see because it's plain
to see that it's not really a river but
there might be there might be a sorry an
underground passage if you can manage
this is going to construct
constitutional walls if you manage to
hold your breath and actually swim I
don't know though si don't less stuff
you guys are going to try it we go for
that where there's swim to safety or we
drown the steel chess is Locke is it
supposed to be laughter did you not find
your stuff no oh
like Justin time I'm sorry I know no
it's cool it's cool I'm it's my bad it's
my bad so what is gonna happen is that
I'm going to drop your stuff in your
inventory [ __ ] I don't know I don't know
what's what is is who's though dead then
so I'll just I'll just do it again I'll
just put everything in
in crate you guys try it can try to open
that crate the one on the right nobody
you should see the stuff alright yeah
yeah you see it okay
so there's stuff missing so I'll I'll
add it to the others Oh Kraig checks all
my stuff whoops my bad oh [ __ ] wait
where to go your ninja ninja equipment
odd drop damn
drop it alright there's more stuff in
the crates yeah this is this is all your
equipment that's where we go yeah that's
why
thank ya so yeah leather so the river
yeah maybe there's like another guard
message however because of the because
of the because of the waterfall is it's
difficult to see you guys should be
silent the goblins have not noticed you
but they might they might alright so
we'll just run for the river try to jump
into the passage and see if we survive
we might die
that could be adequate work hey I enjoy
it pants I'm down though so we just make
a run for it yeah I'm into that
maybe that's fool you ain't got no pants
but yeah stone nice armor sir nice chest
piece okay all right what's the plan you
guys trying to be discreet or just like
me and run it up just run on this oil
yeah we got a dude story y'all did very
well
so we're gonna devout I need to think
for just a second okay now am I gonna do
that so these guys okay you guys are
jumping into the water and the current
sweeps you away so I'm going to ask you
for constitution rolls real quick
Constitution if you have anything I see
that huevo has 12 so that's a plus one
it was very good actually
oh and we had a session so that's
nineteen nineteen six plus one so that's
yeah you do drink a little bit of a
little water though because you're like
yeah drowning and also what happens is
that at some point you like hit a rock
all the weight on the well on the way
there but but I'm sorry very sorry
wrong button but but you just survive
you survive and I just know ii hope that
that's alright
yeah you did it did I'm not I'm not
gonna that was quite heroic I got a say
so quavo yeah you hurt yourself a little
bit not too much though because that was
quite crazy so that's going to be fired
and I think that I'll let you take a
look around and I'm hurtin my head is
hurt I just just just been screwed
because there's something that I would
like to show you guys and then has the
poison barrels okay
oh there's this climbing wall so yeah we
discreetly look around yeah yeah look
around and I I don't know if you guys
can see it from down here um okay you
hear the voice of somebody who's in pain
and it's not a goblin it's actually like
a human force in proper common tone that
says please don't don't don't kill me
just don't please I can I can help you
oh and you know what I'm saying is that
you don't know where it's coming from
like no we had no idea yeah uh well
that's I guess we have no choice but to
look around for this help okay
oh we have like no path oh we can climb
these rocks and I think that's yeah
that's going to be that's going to be
for for our next adventure so we can
found our way to this cave we another
person you did
so I'll uh I'll just I just want to want
to show you guys and then I believe that
below we'll end our adventure here that
you've actually found the cave where a
silver was I'm sorry to The Bodyguard of
the dwarf the other guy was being
detained
oh look around if you move the camera
around I think you can see him that's
the thing I just wanted to show you that
and then I think yeah so that would be a
here's the green I'm it's disc Oh
that's our climate there and so that's
going to be to be continuing sports
adventure alright but well thanks so
much for taking us through this
misadventure and this was put together
by the Wizards of the coast guys but
dungeons dragons team or is this
something that you guys created
specifically ending for the game so we
took the we took the lost mine of hand
over which is the official D&D official
D&D campaign and we adapt it to 4-4-2
our game master mode essentially so we
it's the exact same story exact same
characters in situations just with a
little bit you know adaptive gameplay
gear in there and when you get to the
chance to try these out of course you
have the full divinity to get more
you're going to be able to create your
own campaigns or they're gonna be
campaigns that you can also try out that
are kind of pre-made to see how all that
works oh well I suppose to regarding the
pre-made campaigns I'm not sure I have
to get back to me on that but you can
you can you can make up Sophia any any
campaign a sort of campaign everyone
yeah of course divinity two is still a
development it doesn't have a set
release date but it's gonna be coming
out sometime this year right sometimes
it's yeah yeah well I look forward to
playing more of that and maybe going on
some successful adventures with these
guys um
needless to say we were less than
successful but it was Ella's pretty fun
nonetheless we have ended up naked in a
cave what else could you ask for yeah
have a solve time man well well thanks
so much for watching and for even more
divinity to content once it's released
estate to the game spot calm